[Music]
so
rational thinking frees the divine being
from its contingent shape and in
antithesis to the unthinking wisdom of
the chorus which produces all sorts of
ethical maxims and gives currency to a
host of laws and specific concepts of
duty and of right
lifts these into the simple ideas of the
beautiful
and the good
the movement of this abstraction is the
consciousness of the dialectic contained
in these maxims and laws themselves and
consequently the consciousness of the
vanishing of the absolute validity
previously attaching to them
with the vanishing of the contingent
character and superficial individuality
which imagination lent to the divine
beings all that is left to them as
regards their natural aspect is the
barrenness of their immediate existence
they are clouds an evanescent mist like
those imaginative representations
the essence of these having been given
the form of thought they have become the
simple thoughts of the beautiful and the
good which tolerate being filled with
any kind of content
the power of dialectic not dialectic
knowledge puts specific laws and maxims
of conduct at the mercy of the pleasure
and frivolity of youth which is led
astray by it and provides weapons for
deceiving old age with its fears and
apprehensions and which is restricted to
life in its individual aspect
the pure thoughts of the beautiful and
the good
thus display a comic spectacle
through their liberation from the
opinion which contains both their
specific determinateness as content and
also their absolute determinateness
liberation that is from the firm hold of
consciousness on these determinatenesses
they become empty and just for that
reason the sport of mere opinion and the
caprice of any chance individuality
paragraph
746 seems to be taking us a little bit
away from hegel's
thematic of discussing first epic and
then tragedy and comedy but there is
something of an important element in
what's going on here and there's a lot
of very interesting
things going on within this paragraph
with some hearkening back to
earlier dialectics and notice that in
this particular paragraph hegel in fact
uses the term
dialectical dialectic right in the body
of the text right most of the time he's
doing
dialectics and of course hegelian
dialectics are much more complicated
than thesis antithesis synthesis
nonsense that people try to say when
they're they're being clever right
instead it's you know the the subject uh
the consciousness examining things
trying things out seeing what works what
doesn't work we could go on and on and
i'm not going to
do that right here but he is going to
talk about that here
and a dialectic that has to do with
morality or with ethics so that's
harkening back to some important things
within the spirit and the
reason section we also have
some some reference to the beautiful
and the good
and that too to certain things within
the reasons section but also going back
to thinking about stoicism which is not
so much about the beautiful but is about
the good
as an idea of thought something that
becomes
vacuous like these can be filled with
anything so let's look at what he says
rational thinking fair nunftiga denkin
this is very much a passage in which the
difference between reason or the
rational
and merely understanding merely
representation
based thinking
is is is quite important so rational
thinking is going to do something what
is it going to do
freeze the divine being
the divine reason right uh which as we
see is only there in representation from
its contingent shape and then
in antithesis or and gagan gazettes
right it's not um
antithesis as in contradiction it's in
opposition
in opposition to the unthinking wisdom
of the chorus now unthinking wisdom of
the chorus is not the happiest
translation um
unconceptual would be a more literal
translation because lawson
not using begriff right not using the
concept or the notion that rational
thinking is using and is is deriving
things from
but rather again at the level of
representation or perhaps even just just
feeling right so the unthinking wisdom
vice height
wisdom is being used here in a sort of
ironic sense of the chorus now why the
chorus well because the chorus as we've
seen in tragedy is supposed to be some
sort of stand-in between us the
spectator and the action that is taking
place between
gods and heroes and other other people
other characters the chorus is is a set
of characters who lack character but
don't necessarily lack opinions
right and what do they have at their
disposal so there's some very rich
moral vocabulary going on here the
chorus produces all sorts
of ethical maxims
now
hegel doesn't use the word maxim here
uh
right so
this is a broader term than merely say
conscient maxims or maxims used in other
senses in the 18th and
19th centuries early 19th century right
because that's when hegel is writing
this
um we could call these rules of thumb we
could call these proverbs you know when
somebody says well a bird in the hand is
worth two in the bush right that is a a
maxim
of prudence i should favor the things
that are closer to me and discount those
that are harder to get to right in terms
of value
and then a host
or you know we could use other terms so
there's literally a crowd
and i kind of like this vocabulary a
mess you know a mess of laws
right
actual laws
norms that are governing us
and then he says specific concepts of
duty
and right now notice he's using this
term
right but this is supposed to be
graveslosen so
we've got two different senses in which
concept is being used here and hegel has
done this throughout his works he hasn't
he so flichs on rex
conceptions of duty conceptions of what
is right conceptions of justice
conceptions of normativity what one
ought to be doing the chorus is offering
these not necessarily all at once in
every single play but this is something
that the chorus does right
and so
rational thinking is working on these
and as he says
lifts
right these um
these into a host of law these host of
them into the simple ideas
of the beautiful
and the good
so this is this this whole mess this
crowd of competing and probably
contradictory
uh conceptions of what is right what is
wrong how we should behave all that sort
of stuff
is being transformed into something
through abstraction hegel says
that is the simple idea of the beautiful
and the good
so now
that sounds pretty good
coming back to
the divine being right he says with the
vanishing of the contingent character
and superficial individuality we've seen
this talked about in the previous
paragraphs
which imagination led to the divine
beings all that's left to them
as regards their natural aspect is the
barrenness the nakedness
of their immediate existence and then
he's got this beautiful
phrase here are clouds
an evanescent mist
like those
imaginative representations those
fourstellumen right and so the gods as
we've already seen well they turn out to
be pretty stories cool ideas
almost like you know
comic book heroes or something like that
and they are themselves you could say
simple ideas of the good and the
beautiful
and he goes on that he says the essence
of these having been given the form of
thought
that's what they've become the gods have
turned into
something that
lacks
individuality lacks subjectivity
and now notice he says something here
these will tolerate these can be filled
with
any form of content that's one of the
problems with the ideas of the beautiful
and the good
is they're not determinate enough right
they feel good they sound cool
but what do they really
mean well somebody has to come along
and give them meaning and so he says
the power of dialectic knowledge
right
dialecticia visin
puts now we go back to here specific
laws and maxims of conduct
at the mercy
of something so you you can't totally
get away from determinacy
or specificity stem tight right
in these ideas and now notice what hegel
says next
at the mercy of and here we have
something like a generational
conflict although it's a rather
one-sided conflict the young
the newer generation
is showing up the the older
right and so
the
um
specific laws and maxims of conduct are
at the mercy of the
pleasure and frivolity of youth which is
led astray by it
right so youth is led astray
by
the
this um
and through their their pleasure and
frivolity but
it says provides weapons for deceiving
old age with its fears and apprehensions
which is restricted to life in its
individual aspect
so the younger people they don't truly
know what they're doing but they've got
lots of energy and they enjoy this and
they can take these these laws and rules
and kind of twist them around so what do
you mean old man you know you've already
got this rule in play and they can
engage in dialectic not in the sense of
dialectic that moves forward by itself
but rather the you know well you say
this but this is also the case and these
can't be
uh held together so you're a hypocrite
or you're full of crap or whatever it's
going to be
and that leaves people pretty upset
right
so he says the pure thoughts of the
beautiful and the good
thus display a comic spectacle so there
is still comedy being discussed here
right
through their liberation from the
opinion
which contains both their specific
determinateness as content and also
their absolute determinateness
liberation from the firm hold of
consciousness
on these determinatenesses right so
we are
thinking about these things we are
thinking about them indeterminate uh
specified particular ways we are
engaging in some sort of discussion
between actual people or represented
people
and as soon as we get away from that
towards these these ideas
uh he says
they become empty
because they're empty
they become just for that reason the
sport of mere opinion and the caprice
the
you know
contingency
of any chance individuality anybody can
take these simple ideas of the beautiful
the good and you could say subjectify
them say well my understanding of the
beautiful is this turd on a plate over
here
you don't see that as beautiful oh that
violates all of your your you know norms
and laws and stuff well you know too bad
you know and then
people are like oh this is terrible
right and so we wind up in a kind of
impasse where nobody's ideas are the
ones that get to hold sway or if they do
it's because of contingencies
right and we we're losing a sense of you
might call it meaning or
necessity that we had previously
therefore the fate which up to this
point has lacked consciousness and
consists in an empty repose and oblivion
and is separated from self-consciousness
this fate is now united with
self-consciousness the individual self
is the negative power through which and
in which the gods as also their moments
that is existent nature and the thoughts
of their specific characters vanish
at the same time the individual self is
not the emptiness of this disappearance
but on the contrary preserves itself in
this very nothingness abides with itself
and is the sole actuality in it the
religion of art is consummated and is
completely returned into itself through
the fact that it is the individual
consciousness in the certainty of itself
that exhibits itself as this absolute
power this latter has lost the form of
something presented to consciousness
something altogether separate from
consciousness and alien to it as it as
we're the statue and also the living
beautiful corporeality or the content of
the epic and the powers and persons of
tragedy this unity too
is not the unconscious unity of the cult
and the mysteries on the contrary the
actual self of the actor coincides with
what he impersonates just as the
spectator is completely at home in the
drama performed before him and sees
himself playing in it
what this self-consciousness beholds is
that whatever assumes the form of
essentiality over against it is instead
dissolved in it in its thinking its
existence and its action and is at its
mercy it is the return of everything
universal into the certainty of itself
which
in consequence is this complete loss of
fear and of essential being on the part
of all that is alien
this self-certainty is a state of
spiritual well-being and a repose
therein such as is not to be found
anywhere outside of this comedy
paragraph
747 is now bringing this subsection of
the religion in the form of art namely
the spiritual religion to a close and
it's bringing us to the cusp
of the final not subsection but simply
section
of religion which is the revealed
religion and so what we have here is
for hegel who's
rather schematic about these sorts of
things we're having a transition from
this second section which was primarily
about greek and roman religion
to now considering revealed religion
which will be primarily judaism and
christianity and going through different
permutations of christianity leading up
ultimately to the end where we're
getting ready to move from religion
altogether into philosophy
proper in absolute knowing and we're
getting quite close to the end of the
work of the phenomenology of spirit
at this point
so how does this section end
well
with a little bit of laughter
you could say because he says uh we have
comedy it's the very last word of this
section and he's talking about
self-certainty a state of spiritual
well-being and repose within which is
not to be found anywhere outside of this
comedy as i pointed out many times this
is not an analysis of comedy as a genre
of such or of the comedic in human
beings
and you know when we think about what
comedy means for hegel it's really this
movement at least in this work not
necessarily everywhere else but in this
work it's it's a movement away from all
these
previous
ways of relating ourselves to the divine
and understanding ourselves in
relation to it now
as he starts out fate shikhsal
is
before well let's start with the text
fate which up to this point is lacked
consciousness right so there is it's not
a subject it's something that we
run into along the way we're like oh
crap you know we thought we had some
meaning going on and we followed things
out and boom there's fate or necessity
or whatever it's got different names
and what else he says it's an empty
repose and an oblivion
okay it's
again lacking any sort of determinant
meaning
and was separated from
self-consciousness
very important there now
he says this fate is united there ain't
with self-consciousness how can that be
the case
well
self-consciousness is that very fate
that's how right it's no longer
something that's totally outside of it
separate from it where
self-consciousness is losing things
that it valued now it is part of
self-consciousness
he says the individual self is the
negative power the craft through which
in which the gods
and their moments
exist in nature the thoughts of their
specific character vanish
what else vanishes as well or loses some
of its its meaning i mean they're not
vanishing altogether they are being
evacuated of agency and meaning
the cult and mystery that he talks about
a little bit later
when he says this unity is not the
unconscious unity of the cult and the
mysteries instead we've got something
different going on
a different kind of unity
and these are vanishing so we should now
look back at the text which talks about
the
individual self
here we go the individual self is not
and here hegel is using some really
interesting terminology not the
emptiness
of
the disappearance of the disappearance
of what of the disappearance of the
subject or the disappearance of these
things
emptiness lear height void we could say
right an emptiness of disappearance
an emptiness in which disappearance
fits into figures into an emptiness that
swallows them up think about this a
little bit
because then
immediately afterwards
he's going to talk about a different
kind of
emptiness a different kind of void
one that perhaps is
more active
he says
it preserves itself the individual self
preserves itself
in
this very nothingness now isn't that an
interesting thing to say
indeed
a self of nothingness yeah if we want to
be literal and play around with the the
words it's it's an intensifier right
with this this very this this particular
nothingness
how is this nothingness any different
than any other nothingness like a
nothingness that we can imagine or so
and so is nothingness well there's
literally nothing separating them here
we start to sound rather heideggerian or
sartrian but hegel is already playing
with this dialectic long before
them isn't he and how is this
nothingness this nick kite different
than
their height and emptiness is it a
matter of function
you know these things are swallowed up
in that but the individual self
preserves itself in its nothingness
there's nothing separating those either
if we want to again play in a
heideggerian sense
so he says it preserves itself in this
very nothingness it abides with itself
it is self-consciousness right
and
is the soul uh actuality the only
thing that really is
or exerts itself
now he says something else that's very
interesting here
in this the religion of art is
consummated and has completely returned
into itself
he doesn't say in it religion per se
or all the earlier forms of religion
he's concentrating on the religion of
art
the religion of art is consummated full
ended
can also be translated as fulfilled or
if we want to think about this in a very
greek ancient greek sense it has been
brought to its telos
uh it's sort of like to the italian um
to be brought to which we often
translate as fulfilled right or
perfected is another way of translating
it it has been brought to its fruition
its purpose its end its
what it was supposed to develop into
so that is uh quite an interesting thing
to say the religion of art is
consummated
and he says through the fact that it is
the individual consciousness
in the certainty of itself
certainty of itself that's an important
term there right hegel often has this
dialectic where we begin with
certainty and then we move into truth
and we lose the certainty on the way and
then we want to come back to certainty
certainty of itself in relation to truth
in relation to its other
or the other others that is what's going
on here
it has self-certainty
and it exhibits itself as this absolute
power
so he says the latter has lost the form
of something presented to consciousness
something altogether separate from
consciousness and alien to it and now
hegel says that these other things were
in fact alien to it
even though they really
weren't the statue
the statue we could think about the
architecture as well and the natural
religion right that's being developed in
a sense it is alien it's the god it's
something greater than me but it's also
something i work on
as the craftsperson or worship as the
cult member and then we have the living
beautiful corporeality remember the
dancer uh being discussed before as part
of like a living work of art right and
then we have um he talks about the epic
and and tragedy and he
brings up the content the inhalt of the
epic and the powers and persons of
tragedy so with each of these we've
moved to like something new and there's
the possibility of us kind of distancing
ourselves and being spectators of that
and being like oh that's really cool i
belong to this this community of worship
that cares about this and this
represents me but that's not me well now
i can realize no those things
they are for me i'm kind of the judge of
them right i'm the one or other like me
individuals are the ones who
give them animation who give them agency
who give them
intention
and he goes on and says
the this uh unity we brought this up is
not the unconscious unity of the cult
and mysteries on the contrary the actual
self of the actor
coincides with what he impersonates
the god or the hero impersonated by the
actor
is for the actor and the actor chooses
what they're going to do with it just as
the spectator
is completely at home in the drama
performed before him
and sees himself playing
in it
different relation of the spectator at
this point now
and they're not losing themselves in the
actor's portrayal
in a purely imaginative way this is more
thoughtful this is more dialectical and
for that reason
you could say that the performance is
something we can judge we can appreciate
but we can't fully
lose ourselves in anymore
so he says what this self-consciousness
beholds is whatever assumes the form of
essentiality over against it so the gods
the heroes the cult
the statue
is instead dissolved in it
in in its
actuality
in its as he says it's thinking its
existence and its action and is at its
mercy
before we could say there is a relation
in which the thing that was being
projected as essential a vason of ease
and height was above the human spectator
or actor and now
the position has reversed
the
human being
is revealed as the one that has all
these other things at its mercy
and so he says it is the return of
everything universal into the certainty
of itself which in consequence
is the complete loss of fear
and of essential being on the part of
all that is alien so the fear is lost on
the part of the individual
and the
alien thing uh essential being is lost
on its part so this produces like he
says a state of spiritual well-being and
repose
through comedy now is this like going to
the stand up and
that's so funny listen to them and that
produces that no this is this is
something quite different that hegel is
talking about here don't confuse this
with the genre of all the things that we
call comedy
but instead think about this as the
revelation
of
what tragedy epic
drama in general
statuary dancing all the things that go
into the religious cult
turn out to be
something that wasn't available to the
previous consciousnesses that were
working out and working through
and working upon
all of these things that constituted the
religion of art
you